[Applause]
thank you very much please
sit down it's uh it's nice
thank you it's it's nice to see so many
familiar masks
but i think i know why you're happy
today we are in the yellow zone in l.a
county the yellow zone
whatever the hell that is we're in the
yellow zone
i know it's good it's good it means that
soon all californians are able to do the
things that all
californians want to do like eat in a
restaurant indoors
visit a museum run for governor the
things
all of us do
no we did hey little pat on the back for
us we did good out here los
angeles county has had several days now
this week without
anyone dying from kovic
although although quite a few were
crushed to death by their peloton
treadmill i just have to
[Applause]
do you have one of those well the
peloton finally relent
they're recalling 126 000 of these
treadmills apparently they're dangerous
to small children who can get sucked
into them
and also to parents because they create
the illusion you can run away
uh but
you know what you cannot apparently run
away from did you see this
there's a friggin 23-ton chinese
rocket booster what are you doing this
weekend
that's coming down to earth this weekend
you know the
people countries send up satellites and
[ __ ] and they
you got to send them up on a rocket this
thing is 10 stories high
usually i guess they just orbit this
one's no
going into what they call a uncontrolled
reentry this weekend
uh china said it's very unlikely to
cause any harm and i believe them
because after all one have they ever let
something get
oh there you go
no go on to the next joke they're way
ahead of me they're way ahead of me
that's a good crowd
they even have to finish that joke but
it is mother's day sunday you excited
about that uh
and you know
there's always a uh a heartwarming story
about spawning on mother's day that i
never find heartwarming this week
guess what it is this week in mali the
country of mali
in africa a woman gave birth to nine
babies at the same time take that
octomom
octomom tired molly wired
nine nine babies mom is resting
comfortably
uh dad walks straight into the ocean
with his clothes on
[Applause]
nine babies wow and
for mother's day hallmark has a special
card they made for q anon moms
said roses are red violets are blue
you're the best mom
biden eats babies i i
oh he went on this i have to tell you
i hate to be the bearer of bad news but
the problem in the republican party is
not going away
it is not going away uh the mitt romney
mitt romney you know i was pretty much
against this guy
nine years ago when he ran now he's like
the voice of moderation
went to utah where he's a saint to make
a speech they booed him
off the stage this is like lindsey
graham getting booed on fire island
i mean
and mitt romney he said to the crowd
aren't you embarrassed
and they were like we're 300 pounds
there are crocs on our feet we're
wearing a trump flag as a cape what do
you think
no they are you know the the cuckoo wing
is in control liz chan
another one liz cheney daughter of dick
cheney could you have
deeper republican roots than liz
cheney she's about to lose her
leadership position in the congress
because she will not embrace the idea
that the 2020 election was stolen from
donald trump and the republican party
truth
will set you free from your job
not really a joke but uh a fine idea
was totally not expecting a laugh there
thank you for not giving it to me
would have just encouraged the writers
but you know the problem is that trump
is still out there and he's got a new
platform even though he was thrown off
facebook again facebook by the way this
week they
they they voted they had a big conclave
there they were going to keep they're
going to keep the ban
on trump for another six months off
facebook
because you know
[Applause]
as you know in the next six months he'll
probably change
but but no facebook said if trump wants
to spread his misinformation and his
propaganda he's gonna have to buy ads
like everybody else
uh and
and finally a little sad news in the
marriage department i guess you heard
about bill gates
and melinda gates they are getting
divorced
you that is the exact appropriate
response to that
but you know they lived in a 66 000
square foot house it's so hard to keep a
long-distance relationship together
and uh you know they you know they were
having problems and uh
bill gates you know said they were
traveling problems connecting and he
called his i.t guy
in and he said they they just weren't
compatible
you